[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm just not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and then four and then
oh
huh
uh
that's
oh my gosh this dress is fabulous
[Music]
hi mickey
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
all right
so
[Music]
bye
what's going on
all right
[Music]
sick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
huh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
[Applause]
no i can barely see the screen
[Applause]
[Applause]
did you see olivia
can't
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go away
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
oh my gosh
[Applause]
is
oh
[Music]
good afternoon yale college class of
2021
welcome to the graduates of berkeley
davenport benjamin franklin
and paulie murray colleges
and welcome to family friends and
members of the class
who are joining us virtually via live
stream
we are so excited to have arrived at
this special day
in a few moments we will begin
announcing the graduates as they process
across the commencement stage here in
front of me
but before we start our program a few
words about the land
on which today's ceremony is taking
place
yale acknowledges that indigenous
peoples and nations
including mohegan mashintaka pequot
eastern pequot scattercock
golden hill pogosit niantic
and the quinnipiac and other algonquin
speaking peoples
have stewarded through generations the
lands and waterways
of what is now the state of connecticut
we honor and respect the enduring
relationship
that exists between these peoples and
nations and this land
thank you and please enjoy the program
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates
from berkeley college for the bachelor's
degrees in yale
college when they have been recommended
by the faculty
of yale college and approved by the
corporation
dean chun will ask you by your official
act
to confer upon them these degrees
[Music]
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you
the bachelor's degrees in yale college
when designated by the dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights
and responsibilities
ellen margaret andrews the banner bearer
of berkeley college
rachel coyle and amy zang the procession
marshals of berkeley college
[Applause]
pradi vinayak aggarwal
[Music]
colin bachioko
jennifer leticia benvos
oshani basu chaudry
[Applause]
[Applause]
james foster dunn
michelle erdensana
danielle esposito
kelsey olya evans
[Music]
abigail virginia fortier congratulations
tomiko michelle freisen
[Music]
william j gallagher
[Music]
oshu shane katanaga
juwan gomez aguilar
[Music]
danielle harris
lydia ross hill
johnson
[Applause]
charlotte cavalier
caleb john kim
ananya kumar
[Applause]
claire elizabeth laffin
[Applause]
olivia levine
alice lee
brian lynn
john
[Applause]
henry c liu
[Music]
david lund
timothy larson lewis
zepe ma
caroline lewis mcgavern
zev a mayor
tanvi mihir
helena maria maleo
william thayer mitchell
[Applause]
brianna arielle moore
lynn v nguyen
chaz okada brian oliveira
[Music]
qse omran
daniel o'reilly
anthony m orr
brian lou owens
allegra oh pancreats
amir patel
catherine aura payton
aladia khalifakir patterson
nathan pommier
victoria isabel quintanilla
brian reyes
[Applause]
andrews sinclair richards
marissa rivera
[Music]
dough chad
veronica sosa
william arthur sussman
mary tate
washiki tibbetts
austin twine
anissa a vashi
irene vasquez
[Applause]
candice wong
michael whalen
andesia
annie yang
mary jacqueline yup
[Applause]
joanna zukin
[Applause]
and the graduates participating remotely
[Music]
congratulations berkeley class of 2021
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from paulie murray college
for the bachelor's degrees in yale
college
when they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation dean
chung will ask you by your official act
to confer upon them these degrees
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you
the bachelor's degrees in yale college
when designated by the dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
banner bearer for paulie murray college
lincoln thatcher berkeley and ileana
sophia valdez
procession marshals of poly murray
college
moro aceves acosta
[Applause]
assad
[Applause]
[Music]
jackson robert bando
[Applause]
ornella hereway by gamba
adrian babenick
hannah blankmeyer
michael philip bleacher
sam isaac came rekkosh
brandon ronald chambers
felicia chang
[Applause]
james joseph check
hey hua chen
riley drew constable
hunter ryan cantos
lukasz robert corey
christian ryan crop
[Applause]
die kieran
matthew demotaran
john basil sammer dawud
daniel joseph deprimio
emilia lynn drake
yara noor al-khatib
[Applause]
matthew john erickson
lucas curry ferrer
heather jane foster
chris eugene fowler jr
[Applause]
mila freeman
kevin paul gallagher jr
yashin gao
griffin douglas garrity
patricia annetta gorska
jordan adam grody
layla hallie wright
[Applause]
sarah ann jordan
alexander juliker
nase kanko arthur
[Music]
nash doris bonfield kais
kaznia khan
alexander kirov
[Applause]
jaclyn elizabeth noblesdorf
[Applause]
kate hypatia kushner
julia morgan latham
kyung ah fiolali
justin weaver lilly
[Applause]
violet malone
danielle martin
richard molu wumbo
sarah michelle monahan
hannah ray moreno
emma joan miller
asariman priscilla obuenmudia
claire margaret o'mara
jude anthony salada ong
natalie dorczyd warner
mitchell benjamin ostrow
joshua glenn palmer
rowan mckenzie palmer
johann john park
ryan patrick parkey
amanda lloyd patterson
hua hui an shannon
caitlyn taylor panetta
jordan powell
elizabeth anne chan wong
[Applause]
andrew paul reardon
[Music]
stephen michael riley
emily margaret richards
cesar rodriguez
[Applause]
emma lark rojo
maxwell nadaf solids
kevin omar sanicella
anthony enrique danny sarkis
[Applause]
benjamin kyle tillinger
[Music]
michelle christina tong
[Applause]
gabriel vasquez
nicholas landon wade
daniel junghan wong
skye alexandra de la veron ward
laura lee weyland
[Applause]
amira kaylee williams
tiffany wong
reese maxwell nguyen
jonathan alex shu
hugh lam vanessa yan
sean yee
[Music]
[Music]
zhao and the graduates participating
[Music]
remotely
from prof t and me much lemur love
congratulations to the inaugural class
at paul murray college
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates
from davenport college for the
bachelor's degrees
in yale college when they have been
recommended by the faculty of yale
college
and approved by the corporation dean
chun will ask you
by your official act to confer upon them
these degrees
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon
you the bachelor's degrees in yale
college when designated by the dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights
and responsibilities
jason bradley camp and aydah nas dench
the banner bearers of davenport college
[Applause]
chelsea nicole ilarde and alissa
chisu yoon the procession marshals of
davenport college
ayo damiji orelua abiola
joan chica ago
cameron james fisher allen
[Applause]
rohan sangamish angari
[Applause]
jessica yunju bay
clay andrew bailey ii
steven dennis barbie
alexandra a bauman
[Music]
amira elizabeth billings
[Applause]
victoria bonanno
[Music]
robert anthony brinkman
[Applause]
joshua collier brooks
nicole aaron press gravey brussel faria
maxwell g boo
natalia castellanos gonzalez
[Applause]
hayao fang zhou chao
alan kongshi chen
julia c cherkov
[Applause]
graylin ray chickering
[Applause]
ariel elena claxton
danielle alexis collins
[Applause]
[Music]
seiku lee khande
[Music]
patrick lawrence conte
nicholas ryan dahl
[Music]
cosette elizabeth davis
amy c de la briere
lauren nicole dreisage
[Applause]
genesis victoria duran
natalie anne marie e
a ponge waiter kaki akiye
noah david gershenson
chloe alexandra heller
henderson edward heiser
caleb t hillridge
[Applause]
[Music]
christopher james hudletzig
alexander west heiser hoban
[Applause]
lucas joachim holter
emily rose howell
[Applause]
amanda ibanez
connor w k johnson
nikita joshi
[Applause]
hasn't karem
angel christian kelly
[Applause]
jonathan george kraft
[Applause]
morgan ellie lawson
alexis k lizor
[Applause]
nicholas morin mcnabb
[Applause]
canning olivia malkin
[Music]
daniel james marsh
[Applause]
martinez castillo
[Applause]
ethan david mcbride
william francis mcgint the second
[Music]
brian mendoza
christian a million santiago
mohammed iran munchie
[Applause]
peter hauer nugebauer
[Applause]
ann cooper niels
orlando macmillan nixon
dicacci onyoha
[Applause]
matthew holman peele megan lee quimby
[Applause]
maya haley rayford cohen
[Music]
[Applause]
raj k ramnani
caitlin eileen reese
daniel thomas robinson
katarina paola robles
[Applause]
[Music]
matthew phillips signs
[Applause]
lauren haley singer
talia and pearlman saglin
kevin x tang
[Applause]
sydney rochelle taraso
caitlin elizabeth ties
divine iwaku uche buu
ryan patrick vollmer
[Music]
isabelle sky warner
[Music]
jason nathaniel weinstein
kessie k wilson
[Applause]
[Music]
jackaronda petros walden mariam
[Applause]
nathan shaw wu
angela you
florentine audley xander
[Music]
congratulations davenport class of 2021
[Music]
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from benjamin franklin
college
for the bachelor's degrees of yale
college
when they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation ding
chun will ask you
by your official act to confer upon them
these degrees
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you the bachelor's degrees
in yale college when designated by the
dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights
and responsibilities
tyler joseph jansen banner bear benjamin
franklin college
bamlock ashanafi abigail ashwara mukar
for the procession of benjamin franklin
college
[Applause]
kamara aaron
wasil ahmed
victoria dawn andrew
paul st alban atkinson jr
talia baeza milan
jalen russell bailey
stephanie bang
sarah elizabeth baskin
kieran bocum
[Music]
christina paz bermudez
evan christopher blasey
ivana boccik
jordan carey
nina chesson
[Music]
t victoria chen
colton ford conley
jason lewis continue
isabelle silva corpus
lauren nicole cueto
emma rose deroser
benjamin clifford lee dormis
[Applause]
fred jr abange makolai
[Applause]
[Music]
aya almanzi
madeleine freeman
tony gao
charles harrison gardner
angela gong
carolina sophia gonzalez zapata
spencer chase hageman
[Applause]
morgan hannah gattas
[Applause]
amanda deborah hartzell
maximilian pete tempe
[Applause]
oona o'neil holaham
cindy lauren holmes
mina grace hughes
arthur huang
christopher ursfeld
isabelle elise johnson
leo kazan
[Applause]
[Music]
isabel kulik
[Music]
[Music]
olivia lee
sasha lee
[Music]
sarah melanie lewis
[Music]
catherine lee
shannon ross linder
lauren elise lococo
leila lopez
milat ganana lucigan
[Music]
adam jeffrey madison
mondava
frederick louis zachary montes
[Applause]
talia nash kuhn morris and alan
olivia mosnoy
juliette catherine neal
iragi and kara
emma caroline osborne
joseph ostuno
eric ooh
joseph peck patrick perry
thomas potiglion
[Applause]
caroline pryor
[Applause]
catherine pundick michael pervey jr
aldo ogenio
cindy warner wren
[Music]
imani richardson
logan rivers muriel
rothman mira rothman sorry
zachary austin rudner
abira said
[Music]
isabelle sands francesco mario carlos
garpetta
isaiah schrader
[Applause]
jonathan schwartz vienna gloria stewart
scott
excuse me benjamin shelley
donovan slater
alexis stenger
[Applause]
paul stanky
faith vasquez
tricia viveiros
gwendolyn maya wallace
[Applause]
kathleen segovia wells
lisa wu amanda zhang
namra zufikar andres
kalunga
and our graduates participating remotely
[Music]
congratulations benjamin franklin
so to the students of the class of 2021
and their parents and families and
friends
looking on from around the globe
we gather to recognize the extraordinary
accomplishments
of all of you who have worked so hard
to complete your programs of study
we salute your effort your diligence
your talent and your intellect
we also join you in expressing gratitude
for all who have supported you in these
endeavors
your families and friends teachers
and other members of the yale community
congratulations
class of 2021
hello class of 2021 i'm brian owens
your class secretary four years have
gone by
in the blink of an eye we've made so
many memories
from the first year snowball fight on
old campus right here to the 2019
yale harvard game which we won in double
overtime
to the late nights whether they be in
the library
studying for an exam or in the common
room
talking with our suite mates and friends
although our senior year experience has
not been a traditional one
the class of 2021 has made the best of
the situation
when we leave yale in just a few days we
will leave
with memories and friendships that last
a lifetime
here's to the class of 2021 we did it
[Music]
class of 2021 good afternoon my name is
skye ward and i am a member of the
committee
that organized class today which will
which will air on youtube tomorrow at 2
30 pm
two minutes before 2 30 at 2 28 pm a
special piece written by class day
speaker robert lopez will be played from
harkness tower so keep your ears open
if you haven't already decorated a funny
hat for class day it's not too late
in fact on your seat today you received
a class day 2021 hat that you might want
to use for that purpose
you'll also find a gift bag which
includes items that represent
long-standing class day traditions
as well as others that are new and
unique to the class of 2021
in addition to the class day speaker
tomorrow's program also includes remarks
by members of our class
who've put together outstanding original
speeches and because class day is about
all of us
you'll see your own photographs and
video reflections throughout tomorrow's
program
congratulations class of 2021 and see
you at class day
class of 2021 congratulations i am so
happy to be with you
and to celebrate with you today
graduating is a great accomplishment
one of the most important ones of your
life if you think back to when you first
arrived on campus though no one could
have imagined
that you would live through a global
pandemic before reaching this moment
but you did and thanks to your strength
and perseverance
this moment has finally come i'm honored
to recognize all the work that you have
done to get here
much of it with the support of your
family and friends
today is your day and it is theirs too
today is a day for looking back with
pride at everything you have
accomplished
and all the goals you have reached of
course it brings some sadness to
now that you are ending your bright
college years
but today is a commencement a beginning
so now as you look
uh to the days and years ahead think of
the new achievements
and opportunities in front of you and
look around as well
to remind yourself of the excellent
company joining on this new beginning
your friendships formed at yale
tomorrow you will celebrate class day a
tradition stretching back 150 years
and yale college history i'm excited to
watch the virtual program alongside you
and on monday we can look forward to
president salve's commencement address
i am grateful to the class day committee
to the senior class council
to the university secretary's office to
your college heads and deans
and to everyone who contributed to
making this special events of this
weekend possible
and i'm most appreciative to you for all
that you have brought to yale
and will now bring out to the world with
you
again class of 2021 congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
me
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
you